-You're a stud.
Welcome, welcome, welcome, bud.
-Thank you very much.
-I'm so happy you're here.
Congrats on
"House of the Dragon."
-Thank you.
-Every episode gets
bigger and bigger.
You play Ser Criston Cole,
knight of the Kingsguard.
-Correct.
-Here you are in
full armor right here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And -- Yeah.
It looks heavy. Is it heavy?
-It's quite heavy.
I mean, it got less heavy
as time went on.
But at the beginning,
it was really --
There was, like --
You had, like, a breastplate,
which is, like, a thing
that protects your neck
and, like,
your top of your chest.
But you couldn't remove it.
So, for like the first, like,
2 1/2 weeks of filming,
I had to, like,
sit like a zombie
and have people sort of, like,
feed me like I was very sick.
-You actually shrank
2 inches that day.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Well, you eventually got to be
pretty comfortable
in the suit of armor,
because we have a photo here
that your co-star took of you.
This is you asleep.
-I'm a really ugly sleeper.
It's, like, a real thing.
I see people who sleep really
beautifully. I don't.
-Yes, you --
-I really don't.
-It's pretty perfect
right there.
Did you have any idea Milly
was taking this photo?
-No, I had no idea.
I actually didn't see it until
she put it on social media.
-That's even --
That was my second question.
-Yeah, and now that's it
between us.
-Yeah, now you got to
get her back.
-Yeah, we're done.
-Can we talk about
your character?
Because fan favorite.
We all love you.
And then --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, the fans --
Some fans have started to
turn on you a little bit.
-Yeah.
-They're not into it anymore.
-Yeah, it's interesting.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-How is it as an actor
to go like,
"Oh, hold on a second.
Wait, but I'm --"
-I sort of had inkling
that some people didn't like me.
We went to Comic Con,
and I remember, like,
all the actors lined up.
And I heard a guy go like,
"That guy plays Criston Cole.
I hate that dude."
And I was really confused.
And I was like, "Wow. Already?
It hasn't even come out yet."
-Yeah, the episode
hasn't come out yet
where you're supposed to
hate me.
-Yeah. Exactly, yeah.
-This part, you're actually
supposed to like me.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah.
-And is it tough to have
all these episodes with spoilers
and not telling anyone
what's going on?
-There's HBO people
outside right now.
-Yeah, I met them all.
Yeah. Dangerous people.
-You don't want to mess
with them.
-No, not at all.
Yeah, I'm not going to
spoil anything tonight.
-No, no, no, don't.
-But what happens next episode?
-Yeah, yeah. Good to meet you.
Thank you so much.
-Nice knowing you.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Can you say anything
about what's coming up?
How many episodes are left?
-We did --
Eight came out yesterday?
-Yeah.
-So two.
-So two more left.
-Yes.
-So Is there -- I'm assuming
something for the last episode?
-There will be a last episode.
Something will happen in it.
[ Laughter ]
-You heard it here first, folks.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then, the next episode,
you can kind of coast
through that one?
-Yeah, I'm gonna
coast through that one,
and something will happen
in that one, as well.
And then that will be --
-But, see, I have a feeling
you want me to believe that
because you want me
to coast in there,
and then something crazy is
gonna happen in that episode.
-That's exactly what
I'm setting up today.
-Yeah. And then, when you come
back the next time,
you go, "I'm sorry, Jimmy.
I couldn't let you know
this happened."
-That's what it is.
-Yeah.
-So, if you had to choose
between the next episode
and the last,
which one would you watch first?
-The 11th.
-[ Laughs ]
It's a big deal to be part of
a giant show like this.
How does it feel?
Do you get nervous getting cast
or do you get --
-Yeah, I get really nervous
every time I step on set.
-Do you remember the first time?
-Yeah. Yeah.
The very first day we shot,
it was, like, this huge scene.
It was all
the cast members, like,
Paddy, Rhys, Matt, Liv --
all really good actors.
And, like, they were going
close-ups on everyone,
and everyone was
doing it super-well.
And it, like,
finally got around to my bit,
and all I had -- I had one bit
in the whole scene,
and all I had to do was,
like, roll my eyes,
'cause I was -- They were like,
"Oh, you've got
knight duty tonight."
And I don't know kind of
what kind of came over me,
but, like, I went into some
kind of facial spasm
that, like, was really not what
the scene was supposed to be.
And I thought,
"Well, you know what?
I doubt that anyone's seen it.
There were 53 cameras.
There's surely no way."
And then I saw Miguel, who's,
like, the most astute director,
kind of, like, trudge down
through like 155 extras.
And he was like, "Fabien, what's
up with your face right now?"
And I was like,
"What do you mean, Miguel?"
-"What's up with your face?"
-In what way with it?
I thought it was kind of --
that was right.
That's how my face was --
-You weren't rolling your eyes.
You were twitching or something.
-He was like, "You were kind of
having some kind of
facial spasm."
-Yeah.
-Which I was.
-Yeah, and did you say,
"Look, I'm freaking out"?
-I said,
"I'm having a full-blown --"
Like, I feel now
is how I felt then.
-Are you nervous to be here?
-Yeah.
-No.
-Oh, my God.
I did all the things.
I, like, pulled up my socks,
'cause I was like,
"Well, you don't want to show
kind of leg on 'Jimmy Fallon.'"
-No, we want to see your leg
on our show.
Yeah, show every-- No.
-Yeah, I did all the things.
-Oh, you're crushing it.
-Someone powdered me before I
kind of came on, yeah.
-This is the first of many times
you'll be on our show.
-Well, thank you, Jimmy.
Thank you so much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I want to show a clip.
Here's Fabien Frankel in
"House of the Dragon."
Take a look at this.
-Ooh!
[ Applause ]
-Well done, my Prince.
Be winning tourneys in no time.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Fabien Frankel, everyone.
"House of the Dragon"
airs Sundays at 9:00 p.m.
on HBO and
is streaming on HBO Max.